ladies and gentlemen the President of
the United States Donald Trump liberated
it wasn't a bipartisan vote
nor was it unanimous among Republicans
nonetheless it was an acquittal and this
is really not a news conference it's not
a speech it's not anything it's just
we're sort of it's a celebration because
we have something that just worked out I
mean it worked out we went through hell
unfairly did nothing wrong it did
nothing wrong I've done things wrong in
my life I will admit not purposely but
I've done things wrong but this is what
the end result is this speech complete
with profanities was an airing of
grievances a wronged Trump unleashed
their vicious and men vicious these
people are vicious Adam Schiff is a
vicious horrible person Nancy Pelosi is
a horrible person and she wanted to
impeach a long time ago when she said I
prefer the president I pray for the
prayer pray she may pray but she prays
for the opposite but I doubt she prays
at all he thanks the loyal Republicans
who paved his path to fast acquittal and
Mitch McConnell I want to tell you you
did a fantastic job another prominent
Republican is getting a very different
treatment exposed by news reports as a
Democrats
secret asset senator Mitt Romney's vote
to remove the president from office
prompted the quick release of this
attack video but Romney's pariah status
isn't universal
and God it's hard to see a way out of
this most toxic divide between
Republicans and Democrats Nancy Pelosi
has defended her tearing up of trumps
State of the Union speech and I don't
need any lessons from anybody especially
at president United States about dignity
dignity is it okay to start saying four
more years in the House of
Representatives thank you very much
no one is buying the idea that an
impeached Trump is a chastened one he
enters the 2020 race not just with a
desire to win but with a thirst for
revenge that could take us into
uncharted territory Amanda Walker Sky
News Washington